welcome to best life 30 your 30-day
journey to creating the best life
possible for yourself you can just watch
this video or if you want to sign up for
the entire series for free and get the
companion bonus worksheets that go with
this video check the link in the
description below alright so today is
day 25 and we're gonna learn how you can
learn the skill of persuasion Warren
Buffett was doing the speech of Bill
Gates about maybe 10 years ago and he
was asked by a college student what can
we do as students to make ourselves more
valuable in the workplace
so you think Warren Buffett would say
learn how to pick stocks or investments
you know whenever he would say not what
he says he says go out and take a course
in sales and cos allocation day he did
Dale Carnegie chain says like there you
go now that point because he took they
said I took Dale Kearney changement
without that you don't need me without
that course yeah he'd be the richest
money Nadja in Omaha Nebraska then no
one ever heard of yeah Annie met his
wife that way the love is like because
without the ability to influence and
persuade your cakes you can't put
yourself out there into the world and be
known for what you really are I believe
the leadership is really a skill of
influence is the most important skill
that any human being can master and I
don't think of leadership as a position
I see it as a skill a tool that all of
us have to have in other words the
quality of your life either really
believe comes down to your level of
leadership other people don't have to
follow you to be a leader but you have
to live life on your terms and the first
person you have to influence it yourself
you know whether you're fit or fat you
know whether your kids are out you know
on drugs or not it's who has more
influence the guy on the street corner
or you with your fitter fatness can you
influence your own hands your own body
your own mind to do what's necessary so
I think to be able to influence the
thoughts the feelings the emotions and
the actions of another human being
that's what leadership is I really
believe in order influence people you've
got to know what already influences them
huh the mistake that we make is we don't
connect enough to figure out who this
person is and what most of us do is try
to lead other people by influencing them
the way we've the influence they try to
influence their kid to clean the room
the way that would make you do it but
even though they're your
they're different than you and so
they're gonna do it for a different set
of reasons than what you would do it for
you might have done it because someone
told you to but your kids come all day
long that's not it there has to be
something else it's a sense of freedom
they get from it or a sense of mass just
something that's gonna move them so I
always say there are two things that
influence everyone if you want to be a
leader you have to know how to change
other people's states a person is in a
no state a person's in an angry state
persons in a frustrated state you have
to be able to influence their stake is
if you change their state you're gonna
change the result they get but the
second thing you have to understand is
what are people's blueprints blueprints
my shorthand for what are the values
what do they believe will they fear I
always say to people that life is found
in the dance between what you desire
most and what you fear most if I want to
lead you and support you I got to know
your goals your desires I don't know
what you're scared about what you're
fearful about what stresses you out and
if I understand that I can communicate
in a way that will inspire you to
maximize not only when I'm here that's
management leadership is ongoing you've
raised your own standard and you're
gonna continue to perform at a higher
level I'm incredibly nervous to talk in
front of you because you've got to be
one of the most formidable people that
I've ever heard of or ever listened to
her ever seen so my question is again
you're one of the best communicators
that I've ever listened to if I could be
half as good at you or at communicating
as you are I would be set how can I
teach myself to do that practice you
know really like well there's a couple
of things is helps to read a lot it
really helped to write so if you want to
make yourself articulate which is a very
good idea then not only should you read
but you should write down what you think
and if you can do that a little bit
every day 15 minutes maybe you could
steal 15 minutes and do it every day but
if you do that for ten years you really
straighten out your thinking if you're
gonna speak effectively you have to know
way more than you're talking about
so in a few this is often difficult for
beginning lectures at university because
they'll do a lecture on a topic but they
only know as much as they're saying in
the lecture and they get kind of stuck
to their notes because of it but you
want to know ten times as much as you
are saying in the lecture and then you
can specify a stepping path through it
and elaborate with the other things that
you know but to do that you have to do a
lot of reading but you also have to do a
lot of reading because that's where the
synthesize that's where the synthesizing
comes so that's on the input side and
then on the output side well there's
some tricks techniques let's say is like
if you're speaking in front of a group
you are not delivering a talk to a group
that's not what you're doing the talk
isn't a package thing that you present
to a group there isn't a group there's a
bunch of individuals and you talk to
them so when I talk to a group I always
talk to people one at a time and that
makes it easier to because you know how
to talk to a person it's like can you
talk to a thousand people well probably
not because it's too intimidating but
there isn't a thousand people there
there's a thousand individuals and so
you just look at an individual and you
say something and you can tell if
they're engaged they look confused or
they look interested or they look angry
or they look bored or maybe they're
asleep in which case you look at someone
else and they give you feedback about
how you're doing and so one thing is to
to have something to say yeah but the
next thing is pay attention to who
you're talking to because unless you're
very badly socialized and that seems
unlikely in your case because you know
you present yourself at least moderately
well you know and well I mean I don't
know you very well but at first but on
first sight you know you're doing fine
so the probability that if you pay
attention to the individuals that you're
talking to that your natural wealth of
social skill will manifest itself is
extremely high and so you don't deliver
a talk to an audience that's a really
bad way of thinking about you're
actually engaged in a conversation with
an audience even if they're not talking
they're nodding and shifting position
you know looking like this or and you
can you could pull all that in and and
and use it to govern the level at which
you're addressing the entire audience so
the last thing I would say is well
having the aim to be a good communicator
is a good start and you think well I
could bunch us that to some degree well
there isn't anything that you can
possibly this is the whole point of a
liberal education there isn't anything
that you can possibly do that makes you
more competent in everything you do then
to learn how to communicate I don't care
if you're gonna be a carpenter I mean
being a carpenter by the way is very
difficult especially if you're a good
carpenter but if you're good at
communicating as a carpenter you're like
10 times better as a carpenter so the
and this is something that the liberal
arts colleges I think and I don't know
if they've forgotten it but they don't
do a very good job of marketing it's
like what's the use of a bachelor's
degree a Bachelor of Arts it's like well
you can think you can write you can
speak you've read something it's like
the economic value that is incalculable
the people that I've watched in my life
would be spectacular ly successful or
they have skills clearly that that's a
minimum precondition but they're also
very very good at articulating
themselves and so whenever they
negotiate they're successful well that's
kind of like the definition of success
in life right you negotiate and you're
six it doesn't mean you win because if
you're a good negotiator if you're
really good negotiator everybody walks
away from the negotiation thrilled and
so then people line up to do things with
you so and that's all that's all
dependent on your ability to communicate
so practice persuasion anything so if
you want to persuade your children if
you want to persuade someone to take a
look at your faith if you want to
persuade someone in business if you want
to persuade someone to help you in
anything or help them in anything it's
real simple for me
monster belief and so you can't transfer
to me that which you're not experiencing
yourself right so you can't give me a
people are we starting over the magic
word
the magic clothes the magic this and
there are words you shouldn't shouldn't
use in persuasion no question about it
right there are think there are words
that are more effective in other words
and clearly to be successful in any
business you need to know what those
words are in your business the best
persuaders the best motivators the best
speakers the best physicians the best
schoolteachers the best parents are
incredible persuaders and what they do
is they come from a monster place of
conviction and belief that they can
transfer you to because people respond
to energy much more than they do words
they respond to what they feel not what
they hear and see here and see a real
low level influencers energy spirit
transfer of energy is what people
respond to and so I'm cognizant all the
time of getting in a state of total
belief and certainty about what it is
that I'm gonna represent or speaking of
I'm speaking on stage about a particular
topic and then transferring that energy
into people and that seems generic or
hokey but it's actually what great
persuaders do in fact if you're listen
to this you think of anybody that you
know who's incredibly persuasive they
may have great words they probably do
but it's something you feel from them
right and that's the difference between
a great doctor and a so-so doctor great
doc says here's the prescription you're
out of here another one is they kind of
work or not about now the other one you
leave there feeling that you're going to
be healed settling you're in good hands
you feel their certainty you feel their
confidence saying when you hear a
speaker if you're buying real estate
from somebody but it's not just buying
things it's a great pastor in a church a
great person if you do TM who's taught
you TM it's there's certainty it's the
energy you feel and so for me it's
always getting to I have to really
believe what I'm saying I have to really
feel it to transfer to in communication
skills come in many forms I'm talking
about writing their email while writing
their social media pose or conducting
that meeting or speaking one-on-one
speaking on the phone talking with a
prospect or even speaking to large
groups of people all those falls under
communication skills one of the things
that I did that change my life early on
in my career is I joined Toastmasters to
hold and develop my public speaking
skills and what's also learning from a
mentor to develop my cooperating skill
which is communication in the written
forms how to use words in print to
persuade influence somebody so all
successful people they have this one
thing in common the ability to influence
persuade inspire other people
I believe the easiest way to influence
somebody not to convince them not try to
test the on but the easier to influence
somebody to persuade somebody it's by
asking them questions by asking them
questions so when you know that the idea
is wrong instead of telling people hey
you're wrong
this is no good no one likes to hear
that they are wrong even though they are
wrong they don't want to hear that it's
much better to ask them question hey you
know what now it's okay we can go with
this plan but have you ever thought
about this what are the consequences if
this doesn't work out would it be a good
idea to have a plan B right answer this
maybe it's gonna work but what's the
downside of this right and can we live
with the downside when you throw it out
there and you make a dare idea because
one thing I've learned in persuasion is
this when you say something it means one
thing when they say something it means
everything so instead of you saying it
make them say it make them think about
it make them question it make them doubt
their own ideas versus you try to doubt
their ideas and also when you are
communicating when you're asking
questions you need to ask with certainty
in this world in this uncertain world
what we do is we sell certainty in an
uncertain world that's what we do as
closers as entrepreneurs right as
influencers understand human beings we
tune into the radio frequency called wi
i FM
and that is what's in it for me we are
sometimes very selfish unfortunately
we're thinking about you know why should
I pay attention to this why does it even
matter what's in it for me why should I
even give you the time so when you say
the work you automatically communicates
hey this is something for you pay
attention imagine you are walking down
the street and you hear someone yells
hey you you're like oh is that me is
that me that's the power of that word so
in your messaging in your marketing or
even when you're selling 101
are you using a lot of you are using a
lot of I or V or our company use a lot
more you than I you automatically be
more persuasive let's talk today about
negotiation tactics one of the most
powerful of all is called persuasion by
reciprocation now this is based on what
is called the law of reciprocity it's
considered by many to be the most
powerful law of human nature and what it
says is this if you do something nice
for me I'll do something nice for you
I feel obligated to reciprocate for
example if we go out to lunch together
and I say I'll pick up the lunch you'll
almost always say that I will pay for it
next time and next time you insist on
paying for the lunch now there's several
different types of reciprocation there's
of course emotional reciprocation where
you make people feel good you say thank
you it's a pleasure to meet you I know
how busy you are thank you very much for
your time or this is a beautiful company
or it's a great opportunity for me to
speak to you whenever you say anything
that causes people to feel better about
themselves they have a deep unconscious
need to reciprocate there's another type
of reciprocation which is called
material or financial reciprocation when
you do something physical for someone
for example you help someone load their
car they want to help you load their car
you lend see people money or your
lawnmower they want to pay you back by
precipitating in some way we always like
to do things for others because we have
according to psychologists this deep
need to be even so if you do something
for me the only way that I can get even
is by doing something for you by the way
the reverse is also true if you do
something that hurts me that I feel a
deep need to get even as well so be
careful so the starting point of
reciprocation is look for opportunities
to do things for others something as
simple as bringing a cutout from a
newspaper that may be of interest to a
prospect something as simple as giving a
person a book or something like that
something as simple as opening the door
or getting a cup of coffee it's a very
powerful technique to cause people to
like you and to feel obligated to you
how do I add more value so that I can
get paid more so that I can have more
influence so that I can make more of a
difference where I'm at everyone you
always hear it all the time right add
more value well how how do you add more
value so you can get paid more and have
more influence part of adding value is
helping people reconnect with some
emotional side of their lives right I
know that sounds so simple in some ways
but also philosophical that a lot of
what we experience today in this world
is is is just so cheap and so
commoditized and so technically driven
that it's our job if we want to add a
lot of value to bring back in humanity
to bring back in the emotion to bring
back in the color the flair the joy the
vibrancy the real hues of human emotion
that are often missing from everything
if you bring that back into everything
that you're contributing you'll go to a
level of adding value that most people
never understand and people won't just
follow you because you're the person who
asks the question best questions people
would just follow you because you're the
person who knows the most people people
will follow you because you're an
inspire and you're a leader because they
can see within you that you have true
energy true engagement to human emotion
with everything that could contributing
and because of that they know that
you're somebody they want to follow the
number one way to influence another
human being is actually by your exam
I mean we are tribal we are we used to
travel in herds we are profoundly
influenced by the social networks we are
around and so if you want to influence
and elevate and uplift people around you
start with you start with your example I
love Aesop's fables and um so I'm gonna
tell this story one of the most famous
and I think most useful of Aesop's
fables so this is the fable of the wind
and the Sun so the wind and the Sun were
having an argument about who was the
more powerful and they decided that they
would settle it with a bet and what they
bet was that they spotted a traveller on
a road and they said who was would be
able to get the cloak away from that
traveller and whoever did was the
stronger so the wind went first and the
wind turned on his mighty force and blue
icy wind at the traveler and almost blew
the cloak right off of the travelers
shoulders but the traveller was you know
felt the wind felt the cold and so
gripped the cloak so tightly that
eventually the wind had to give up and
said that he couldn't get the cloak away
from the traveller so then it was the
sun's turn and the Sun shone down on the
traveller like these beaming rays and as
the traveller walked along he loosened
his grip and eventually he was became so
hot that he ripped the cloak off and
threw it on the ground and the Sun won
and so the moral of the fable is that
persuasion is more powerful than force
in robert cialdini's book influence he
says a well-known principle of human
behavior says that when we ask someone
to do a favour we will be more
successful if we provide a reason here's
an example from that book listen to this
a woman was standing in line for a copy
machine and she said excuse me I have
five pages may I go ahead of you and
make my copies 60% of people said yes
now listen to this
she tried asking a slightly different
way she gave a reason why this time she
said excuse me I have five pages may I
use the copy machine because um
and this time 94% of the people said yes
that's one and a half times as many that
is a lot of persuasion now there's more
to that study and you can check it out
in chill teenies book but the point here
is that when you give people a reason
why you're asking for something they're
more inclined to give it to you now I've
got a special bonus cup that I think
you're gonna enjoy but before that it's
time for the best live 30 questions of
the day it's not enough to just watch a
video you have to do something about it
so pull out your worksheets and answer
these questions and if you don't have
the worksheets yet get them for free by
checking the link in the description
below here we go question number one
what persuasion skills will you work on
this week number two how can you add
more value to the people in your life
and number three where do you need to
leave more by example and if you're
doing the best live 30 challenge with me
put a hashtag best live 30 in the
comments below we want to celebrate you
so listen as an entrepreneur if you do
not know how to influence and persuade
your company is done this is a challenge
for so many entrepreneurs you have a
great mission you have a great message
you're trying to do things for the right
reason you're not just trying to make
money make money is important but it's
not number one does something else a you
trying to accomplish but because you
don't know how to influence and persuade
people you can't get customers you can't
get suppliers you can't get people to
join your team you can't get media
coverage you can't get the traction that
you need because you cannot do this
thing all alone it's impossible to do
any business all alone even if even if
you're the only person in your company
you still need to sell to people right
you still need the ability to be able to
influence and persuade and I love that
more than I love this the term is
selling I think people often associate
selling with something negative which it
can be it has a slimy connotation
sometimes for some people but the
ability to influence and persuade it
doesn't mean you're pushing people to do
something that is against their own best
interests it's the exact opposite I mean
you can use influence persuade to hurt
people I want you to use it for the
positive what I do all day long is just
see people and their their genius level
talent I see you as being Michael Jordan
level talent at whatever it is you will
have to do you have that ability and my
entire goal is to move you from where
you are right now with these limitations
in this belief system to play
appear to play in a bigger game it's why
I make these videos every single day and
hopefully I'm able to move enough of you
then that makes a difference and so I
want that same thing for you you want to
make a powerful positive impact in the
world to do that you need the ability to
move people you need the ability to
influence and persuade or your company
is not gonna go anywhere so let me give
you three simple ways on how to do it
for your company right now
number one is transfer emotion you have
to understand this is where so many
people get locked up it's not about the
specific words that you say it's about
transferring emotion it's about you
feeling something in here you feel it
this is really important and then making
the other person also feel that it's
really important one of the best advice
that I got from my agent who helped me
with my youtube channel and get better
after thousands of videos well as he
kept saying raise the stakes raise the
stakes raise the stakes make it more
important make me feel something I was
so concerned about getting the specific
words out right that it came across as
boring and memorized and robotic and
without care we're way more important
than memorizing those words is the
energy is me feeling like this is
important because if I feel it you guys
will feel it too
if in whatever you're creating
especially if it's video content but
regardless if it's video if it's
face-to-face if it's written content you
have to feel the words this has to be
important
this has to be life-changing if you feel
that your message is life-changing then
it will be for some people but if you
are just so worried about getting the
words out that every little mistake you
freaked out and you don't have
confidence in your voice
you're gonna lose you won't bring people
along I like to say that when I'm 85
percent sure I'm a hundred percent sure
because you can never be a hundred
percent sure looking forward only
backwards what why go from 85 to 100 is
because if you have confidence then your
confidence will bring people along board
with you if you're 85% and you act like
eighty-five percent people will tag on
to that 15 percent of uncertainty and
they won't make a decision even if it's
in their own best interest even if they
are letting themselves down they won't
act because you're uncertain because if
you have uncertainty in the advice that
you are giving then they will have
uncertainty and they won't do it they
won't take action so the ability to
influence persuade starts number one
with the ability to transfer emotion to
transfer energy to transfer certainty
you have to feel the message first and
then they will too
tip number two is study people who are
great at it just like any other skill
that you want to learn study the people
who are great at influencing and
persuading and here's the side note to
it even the people who you hate so
Jordan Belfort is a great example I
think of all the videos and all the
people that I do Jordan Belfort gets
amongst the most hate because of you
went to jail people don't like that I
featured a criminal on my channel great
there's a lot from all the people that I
profiled that I that I don't want to
learn from you know I may not want to be
a father like Steve Jobs but there's a
lot that I can learn from him
whether you completely hate Jordan
Belfort as a man or not you can still
learn from him if you love Jordan
Belfort great if you hate him great when
you can unbox yourself to say I'm only
gonna learn from from this kind of
person this really limited way of
learning that's the only way I'm gonna
learn and say I can learn for anybody
who could teach me and even if I
absolutely hate that person they still
have something to teach me I'm gonna I'm
gonna ignore all the stuff that I hate
from them and I'm gonna take that one
thing it's gonna make me better when you
can learn to learn from the people that
you hate that's when you really grow
because they might have one thing that
can make you the best version of you and
that's the only thing that you should be
focused on and tip number three is to
practice practice practice the more you
do it the better you're gonna get at
like everything else ever always use the
ability in even little tiny micro
situations whether it's with your
brothers or sisters or kids or parents
or spouses or boyfriends or girlfriends
or classmates or customers or partners
or suppliers or investors always try
always always push things a little bit
more think about what you want from them
here's the game that I always play
what's in their best interest the person
who I'm talking to what's in their best
interest I try not to be a little Evan
voice on their shoulder I try to be the
best version of them on their shoulder I
try to tell them the thing that they
should be telling themselves that they
want to be telling themselves and I give
them the confidence to be able to go off
and do the thing that they want to do
and so when you catch it when you
recognize it when you see it when you
see that this person is letting themself
down in some way when you see that this
is the thing that they should be off and
doing then you may not need to go
hardcore on them and freak out and rage
on them practice practice take your baby
steps but just practice doing it try
some of the techniques that you've
learned try
Xtreme better emotion try modeling more
success and see what technique suits
really well for you and the more you
practice just like everything else the
better you're gonna get I think this is
a skill like everything else I think is
a skill you can learn I think if you
tell yourself that you suck at
influencing people then then you will
forever and always what if you say you
know what I may not be good at it right
now but it's a skill that I want to
learn then you can get better at it if
you want to join the best life 30
challenge click the link right here
below me or if you want more videos on
how to persuade more effectively check
out the playlist right there next to me
continue to believe and I'll see you
soon